former U.S president Donald Trump has
been indicted by a grand jury in New
York after an investigation into alleged
hush money payments made by his former
lawyer to an adult film star this is
said to have happened just before the
2016 presidential election it would be
the first time a former U.S president
has been charged with a crime Kristen
salumi begins our coverage from New York
adult film star Stormy Daniels and her
alleged sexual encounter with Donald
Trump is at the center of the criminal
case against the former president after
she threatened to go public about the
affair in the final days of Trump's 2016
presidential campaign trumps then fixer
Michael Cohen paid her 130 thousand
dollars to keep quiet Cohen who
testified before the grand jury has said
he made the payment at Trump's Direction
and in 2018 pleaded guilty to violating
campaign Finance laws for which he
served time in prison it's not Revenge
right what this is is that
accountability I don't want to see
anyone including Donald Trump indicted
prosecuted convicted incarcerated simply
because I fundamentally disagree with
them this is all about accountability he
needs to be held accountable for his
Dirty Deeds the former president has
always denied the affair he also
initially denied any knowledge of the
payment but now says it took place as a
legitimate legal expense
[Music]
under New York law it is the
falsification of business records not
the payment itself that would be Trump's
crime a misdemeanor and only if
prosecutors can prove he made the
payment and falsified records
specifically to hide the affairs from
voters or the IRS would it be a felony
or more serious crime that could come
with jail time the falsification of
records for the purpose of committing
tax evasion would be the additional
specific crime to elevate falsification
of business records from a misdemeanor
to a felony so he he need he needs
something like that complicating any
prosecution Cohen's former legal advisor
a trump Ally told the grand jury Cohen
couldn't be trusted no listen if they
want to go after Donald Trump and they
have solid evidence so be it but Michael
Cohn is far from solid evidence
president Trump has described this case
as a Witch Hunt but it's far from the
only Criminal investig gation he's
facing in Georgia prosecutors are
looking into his alleged attempt to
overturn Joe Biden's victory in the
state in 2020 and several government
bodies are investigating his alleged
role in the attack on the U.S Capitol on
January 6 2021. the case marks the first
time in history that a U.S president has
faced criminal charges Kristen salumi Al
Jazeera New York
well Donald Trump has himself reacted in
a statement he called the indictment
political persecution and election
interference at the highest level in
history
he blamed it on what he called radical
left Democrats engaged in a Witch Hunt
to destroy the make America great again
movement
and he said This Witch Hunt will
backfire massively on Joe Biden
well Mike Hanna joins us live now from
Washington DC so my fast moving
developments with this what's the very
latest you can tell us
yes indeed there will you mention the uh
peace on his social media page that
Donald Trump has just written among
those many sentences as well he said
that this is an attack in our country
the likes of which has never been seen
before it's likewise an ongoing attack
on our free and fair elections now to
put this into a context yesterday 24
hours ago on exactly the same social
media page Donald Trump wrote I have
gained such respect for this grand jury
and perhaps even the grand jury system
as a whole so 24 hours is a long time
because the grand jury has now indicted
Donald Trump but despite the fact that
he had gained such respect for it what
happens next well the indictment will be
served on Donald Trump's lawyers he will
then be given the option to surrender to
a Manhattan court or if he doesn't he
could well be arrested but then you've
got a situation if Trump remains in
Florida as he is at present there has to
be an next tradition deal done by New
York with the state of Florida so
there's a lot of aspects in sight here
Trump's lawyers have indicated that he
may surrender he may appear in that
Manhattan Court what will then happen is
that he will be fingerprinted he'll be
processed his photo will be taken and
then the formal charges will be laid and
is probably only at that point that we
will know exactly what these charges are
at the moment or we know from many media
reports and from Trump's lawyers
themselves is that the grand jury has
agreed on an indictment the content of
the statement the nature of the charges
not known at present and like where does
this leave Trump then in terms of the uh
well running for president
well it's a major issue there's two
sides to look at it Donald Trump himself
appears to relish the possibility of
fighting a campaign with these charges
hanging over his head we've already seen
in recent days him attempting to get his
supporters out onto the street as he put
it because of these pending charges
announcing prematurely that the
indictment had been issued even though
it had not at that particular point in
time but then of course as detractors
would argue that this just points to his
failures as a person and that he would
not get the vote should he stand in that
ongoing 24 election I must add as well
that should he be convicted or even put
into prison that does not prevent him
from running for the presidency this is
a particular quirk in the United States
you can't vote if you're fill in or if
you are in prison however you can run
for president because the Constitution
doesn't say anything about convicted
villains not being able to run for
president in fact there have been at
least two occasions in the past where
somebody in prison has attempted a
presidential race that is an extreme
supposition that's an extreme case
obviously we don't know what the charges
are we don't know what a sentence would
be should he be found guilty of those
charges those are all factors that need
to play out in the weeks and months
ahead Mike Hannah in Washington DC thank
you
well staying with this now let's bring
in Adolfo Franco he's a lawyer and a
Republican strategist he joins us from
Washington DC welcome to the program so
firstly what do you make of the fact
that this has actually happened it's
extraordinary isn't it
it is extraordinary but it's an
extraordinarily sad day for the country
uh overall despite the one's views one
way or the other of Donald Trump this is
this is entering new territory for the
United States and it is depending on
your point of view and I certainly have
one political persecution and when you
have that sense in America it's a first
so it's a an extraordinary I actually
thought it might not happen considering
some of the late developments in terms
of the grand jury deliberations of last
week and Mr Cohen's testimony and and so
forth it seemed to to have a pause but
it was otherwise Donald Trump can still
stand in the presidential election as
we've heard does that work for him or
against him in the eyes of Voters
well I think certainly we'll see how
this plays out we haven't seen the
details of of the indictment uh but
certainly in the short term it has
already been paid dividends since uh
president Trump announced a couple of
weeks ago that he was on the verge of
being indicted uh so uh it's very clear
uh that this will uh further uh help him
in the primary there's no question I
can't imagine any of the the uh declared
uh the few declared uh Republican uh
primary candidates for president that
will not come to his defense as well as
the ones that are Undeclared Governor
DeSantis uh former vice president Pence
and others already the Republican
reaction has been a very very strong
much more strong the Democrat reaction
so forth as is being outrageous and
calling for Congressional investigations
and labeling it a political persecution
in the country entering into stage of
becoming really a Banana Republic where
does this leave his Rivals there as you
mentioned and for the Republican
nomination it puts them in an awkward
position doesn't it
it certainly does it already was very
difficult for any of the credible
candidates or possible candidates uh for
the Republican nomination in 2024
already had difficulties distinguishing
themselves from president Trump they
have been approaching this gingerly a
little bit on the age issue uh and that
type of thing uh but they all support
the Trump policies uh so it was always
already a difficult task now you have
political martyrdom in many ways on the
Republican side I'm talking about
Republican primary voters so it becomes
very very difficult for them they have
to support and will support president
Trump in this process at least initially
as it plays out longer term we shall see
if Republican potential Republican
candidates can start to say although
this is unfortunate it will cost us in
the general with Independence and try to
persuade hardcore Trump uh supporters to
uh switch Allegiance only to win the
general election but that's very very
difficult to do okay not many Democrats
and some Republicans might say look this
reveals a poor character lack of
humility you know Trump is a loser he
lost the election why would you want him
to be the uh the candidate with all this
extra baggage going on
well there are a couple of things going
on in the country first of all and I
think the opinion polls show it when you
have a president at 38 in one poll 38
approval rating and the vice president
at 36 approval rating and then and uh 64
percent of the American people saying
that President Biden shouldn't run for
reelection you have a weak president
there's no question so there's a vacuum
so there's a yearning for the Trump
years those were actually very good
years in terms of the prosperity of the
economy we were at peace that that uh
agenda was working for for most
Americans so uh there's that contrast
that President Biden can't run away from
his record why president Trump is
because of that he has a four-year
record people attack Donald Trump the
person the behavior Etc but the policies
are enormously popular with the American
people and again uh you might have some
appeal with other candidates saying
they'll pursue Trump policies but
there's a fear there's only one gen When
Donald Trump and therefore I think he
will Garner support among Republicans
and possibly among Independents and
Democrats if this indictment and
eventually uh whatever trial or whatever
ensue is next if it falls apart it will
then be perceived as political
persecution and could really uh put him
in a position to win the White House in
2024. that's Alpha Franco we'll leave it
there we very much appreciate your time
thank you
thank you so much
let's speak to Gabriel Elizondo who's
outside the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office in New York so what's
happening where you are now then
well we're waiting we're waiting to see
if we're going to hear any statement
from Alvin Bragg the district attorney
here in Manhattan or if we will actually
get to see that indictment that
apparently was signed by the grand jury
why haven't we seen it yet and that's
because it's under seal and that's
normal under grand jury procedures such
as this whenever the grand jury issues
an indictment it does not that
indictment does not go out in a press
release immediately it does not
immediately public information it would
entail district attorney Alvin Bragg to
ask a judge to unseal that and make it
public and as of now that has not
happened so what are we waiting for now
here outside the Manhattan DA's office
is we're waiting for eventually uh
Donald Trump to arrive here to
potentially be a rain that is the next
step when could that happen anytime
really normally in proceeding things
like this after someone is indicted the
district attorney will call that
person's lawyer advised them that they
were indicted and then they will make an
arrangement or go into negotiations
about when that person that was indicted
would arrive here to to have their first
court appearance that could be
potentially as early as tonight or
tomorrow or within the next couple days
we simply don't know right now why we
don't know a lot of information is
because this is very much A Private
Matter and what I mean private I mean it
is not public this is not held in open
court this is a a grand jury that is
everything is done in secret so uh we're
waiting here to see if we can get more
information from the district attorney
Alvin Bragg but he's under no obligation
to give more information at this point
uh it's just a matter of if he chooses
to at this juncture or not and at some
point I mean How likely are we to see
Donald Trump in handcuffs or anything
like that or is that not lucky to have
this doesn't quite work like that in
these kind of cases
foreign
normally under indictments someone would
come in and it's all it's called a
procedure you know Donald Trump has come
out and said I'm going to be arrested he
has said I will you know there's Trump
supporters saying he is going to be put
in handcuffs not necessarily the case uh
these are un this is unprecedented of
course but I can tell you normally in
Grand Jury proceedings like this when
someone has indicted assuming the person
is willing to come to the courthouse
give their fingerprints and do an
arraignment which Donald Trump and his
lawyers said that he would be prepared
to do they would not necessarily be put
in handcuffs uh so you know
unlikely we'll see him in handcuffs but
event but of course these are very
unprecedented times but normally in a in
a grand jury indictment like this white
collar situation crimes such as this
alleged crime such as this you would not
see Donald Trump in handcuffs
nevertheless Donald Trump is certainly a
showman and he wants to make this part
of his campaign going forward because he
has said he views this as political
persecution uh we know Donald Trump of
course he is a showman so uh there is
certainly a lot of people commenting and
speculating that he will want to arrive
here at this Courthouse to show that he
is in his words uh being politically
persecuted and so we just have to Simply
wait and see there is a huge security
apparatus that is taking place right now
in lower Manhattan where I'm at right
now uh between the Secret Service the
FBI API and the New York Police
Department there are helicopters buzzing
up above as you might be able to hear
right now they are preparing to make
this as secure as a Handover if you will
as possible when Donald Trump
potentially arrives here will he go
through the front door will they drive
him to an underground parking lot will
they take him through a back door will
Donald Trump demand to go out to the
front steps of the DA's office and give
a press conference we just do not know
right now and that is the big
uncertainty I should say the normal
procedure here under Grandeur
indictments is the person in this case
Donald Trump would arrive here at the
DA's office would go into the DA's
office would give fingerprints take a
mug shot a a photograph after that
procedure is done the next step would be
they walk down a hallway for their first
court arraignment with a judge they
would be arraigned in front of a judge
be told of their rights and and the uh
uh the grand jury indictment against
them and then they would be free to
leave that is the normal procedure and
that could happen
as early as Friday we think but again it
could this is an arrangement this is a
negotiation between the District
Attorney's Office the judge and Donald
Trump's lawyers moving forward but at
some point he will Donald Trump will
have to be arraigned in front of a judge
and or his lawyers
Gabriel for now thank you for that
other news now a court in Russia has
ordered the Detention of a U.S
journalist on Espionage charges Yvonne
gershkovic works for the Wall Street
Journal it'll be held for two months in
pre-trial detention he told the court he
was not guilty The Wall Street Journal
says it's worried for his safety
goshkovich was initially detained in the
city of nikatarinburg and then brought
to Moscow the White House says all U.S
citizens in Russia should leave
immediately
Notch charges are ridiculous the
targeting of American citizens by
Russian government is unacceptable
we condemn the Detention of Mr gerskovic
in the strongest in the strongest terms
we also condemn the Russian government's
continued targeting and repression of
journalists
Aussie and Jordan has more from the
state department in Washington D.C on
the U.S government's action plan
well the first priority according to the
principle of Deputy spokesperson vadant
Patel is for the U.S embassy in Moscow
to gain Consular access to Mr
gershkovich this is something that is
guaranteed by International treaty but
as we have seen in the recent case of
the WNBA player Brittany Greiner it was
very difficult for Consular officials to
get to see Ms Greiner while she was
being held in prison for the better part
of a year it's also been very difficult
for U.S officials to meet with Paul
Whelan the former Marine who had been
convicted of Espionage and is being held
for 16 years in a Russian prison so that
is the first priority it is worth
pointing out that gerskovic was detained
while he was on a reporting trip to
yakonerenberg about 600 1600 kilometers
east of Moscow and the consulate there
was not informed that that he had been
detained until he turned up on Thursday
now it's also a question and officials
at the state department and at the White
House don't want to answer this question
will Evan gershkovich be considered
wrongfully detained that's an added
layer of urgency to an Americans case
when that person is being held by a
foreign government for whatever reason
and certainly being charged with
Espionage is perhaps a much more serious
charge in terms of diplomatic relations
than in the case of Brittany Greiner
being found with the small amount of
hashish in her traveling luggage
now we're just going to go back to our
top story of Donald Trump's indictment
and speak to Gabriel Elizondo again
who's outside the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office in New York we
understand you have some new information
yeah just within the last minute and a
half or so we've just got an official
confirmation from the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office it's a brief statement
and I'm just going to read it word for
word it says this evening we contacted
Mr Trump's attorney to coordinate his
surrender to the Manhattan DA's office
for arraignment on a supreme court
indictment which remains under seal
guidance will be provided when the
arraignment date is selected so that is
official confirmation from the Manhattan
district attorney's office that the
indictment has been handed down against
Donald Trump they have advised Mr
Trump's lawyers and that the official
indictment as I mentioned just a few
minutes ago to you is under seal which
means it has not yet been made public
the official indictment and then of
course guidance will be provided when
the arraignment date is selected the
that would be the date when Donald Trump
needs to appear here and be arraigned in
front of a judge and also give
fingerprints and a photo to the
Manhattan District Attorney's office so
this statement the First full
confirmation from the Manhattan district
attorney's office that Donald J Trump
has been indicted by a Manhattan grand
jury historic because as we've been
reporting of course this Donald Trump
now becomes the first U.S president in
history to ever be indicted for criminal
charges now it's important to point out
and this cannot be said enough and
indictment is not I repeat is not
necessarily a conviction what an
indictment is it's a group of 23 Grand
jurors he's a regular citizens that were
presented evidence from the Manhattan
D.A and said that Donald there is enough
evidence that Donald Trump in this case
should go to trial for his alleged
crimes that is an indictment he will now
potentially now the next step is go to
trial and that is where a jury will
decide if he's guilty or not guilty
Gabriel Alexander with that breaking
update thank you